Racing for revenge.
The sound
of air
raid sirens
heard across Ukraine's capital
as the city prepares
for Russia
to retaliate
after the Kremlin says
it prevented an assassination
attempt on Vladimir
Putin on Russian state TV.
This right here is the message
of the everyday control centers.
The presidential office in Kiev
and the government building
should be turned into dust.
There is a wound
you will not see
those sorts of threads
creating chaos
in the streets of Kiev
after a low flying
drone was spotted in the capital.
You could see it being hit
right there
and then going down
in this ball of flames.
Shortly after that incident,
Ukraine acknowledging
the drone was one of its own shot down
because Ukraine lost control of it.
Now, this was a sigh of relief,
but one that may be short lived.
Meanwhile, Russia
ramping up its claims that yesterday's
drone strike on
the Kremlin was carried out
by Ukraine and the U.S.
And tonight the US is responding.
I know there's lots of questions,
but we just don't have
conclusive evidence.
One thing I can tell you for certain
is that the United States
was not involved in this incident
in any way, contrary to Mr. Peskov lies.
And that's what they are, just lies.
And in a moment, I'm
going to
speak to a former Russian lawmaker
who told CNN exclusively
that it was Russian partizans
and not Ukraine behind
these drone attacks on the Kremlin.
Insight
he first shared with our Matthew Chance,
who has been covering
this story extensively.
Matthew,
what more are you learning tonight?
Well, tonight
there's a lot happening in Russia
because Russian television
is reporting
more drone strikes in multiple locations
across the country,
particularly in areas
close to the Ukrainian border.
This as
the Kremlin vows to press ahead
with the victory day
celebrations, the military parade
that scheduled in
in a few days from now,
despite
those dramatic drone
strikes on the Kremlin earlier this week.
60 Minutes, the Kremlin version
with breaking news of three
more attempted
drone strikes on Russian soil.
The anchor, a
Kremlin mouthpiece,
tells her millions of viewers
how to attacks
on oil facilities were unsuccessful.
Com crime branch cold list.
But another targeting a village near
the Ukrainian border,
she admits got through.
Increasingly, Russia's war in Ukraine
is coming home now.
Acceptance comes with the virus.
Just hours before,
it was the Kremlin itself
in the line of fire,
a Ukrainian assassination
attempt on President Putin said officials
denied by Ukraine.
Now the Kremlin says it's
the United States that's to blame.
I mean, we know very well that decisions
about such actions,
about such terrorist
attacks are made not in Kiev,
but in Washington,
even in the
Washington, Kiev and Kiev does
what it is told to do.
There's a word
that comes to mind
that I'm obviously not.
Not appropriate.
But U.S. officials are pushing back.
Mr. PESKOV Lying.
I mean, that's
obviously it's a ludicrous claim.
The United States
had nothing to do with this.
We don't even know
exactly what happened here, Caitlin.
But I can assure you
the United States had had no role in it
whatsoever.
But Ukraine is bracing itself
for a further Russian response.
Earlier, Russian drones
with messages for Moscow
and for the Kremlin
scrawled on them were intercepted.
All this as Ukraine's president
is on
an unannounced European tour,
briefly stopping in The Hague
in the Netherlands
to condemn his Russian counterpart.
Of course, we all want to see a different
Vladimir here
in The Hague, the one who deserves to be
sentenced
for these criminal actions.
Back in the capital
of the Russian Federation,
Muscovites seem unfazed,
at least publicly,
by the extraordinary events
unfolding in their city.
The only person who that goes
on a drone strike on
the Kremlin
was going to happen
sooner or later, says this man, Nikita.
If again,
we live in an awesome
country, says Anastasia. Here.
The best protected in the world.
Even more shocking than that,
someone
was able to penetrate those defenses
and attack.
Yeah, shocking indeed.
Well, tonight,
of course,
the Kremlin is lashing out
still at Ukraine,
the United States as well.
But Pamela,
the fact is that drone strikes,
political assassinations, arson attacks,
they've all in the past 12 months
or so become a fact of everyday
Russian life. Back to you.
Matthew Chance, thank you.
OUTFRONT now, Ilya Ponomarev.
He is a former Russian lawmaker
who was forced into exile
after he became
the only Russian lawmaker
to vote against
the annexation of Crimea
by Russia in 2014.
So, as I mentioned, you told Matthew
that you believe
the drone attack on the Kremlin
was the work of Russian partizans.
Why do you believe that?
With everything,
I just don't simply believe it.
I know it as a fact.
I know the people who actually produce
those drones.
Those drones were so made.
They were not factory manufactured.
We are discussing that they had plans to
attack the Red Square on the 9th of May.
But since these days, very special
for the hearts of Russians
and the Russians
themselves,
they were thinking that
maybe it would be better
to make a warning. Strike me, Vladimir.
Which to cancel
the military parade
on the 9th of May altogether.
So you talk to them directly.
Is that what you're saying,
that you discussed this with them?
Yes.
Matthew, as you just heard there,
I just mentioned other drone
strikes in Russia.
Do you think Russian partizans
are behind those two?
Well, they
there are different attacks
because there are attacks
that have military meaning
and the attacks on the will refineries
or oil storages
that were happening next
to the Ukrainian border.
At least most of them for sure.
The effects
that were carried out by Ukrainian
security forces
who are preparing for the offensive
and they are cutting off the supply.
So while the military good some for
the few will and can really
by the way the first attack
on the
one of the refineries
that were affected
recently in the Washington
City Point
that was done by Russian partizans
from out of region
and at that time it was a big scandal.
And there was the one
Washington guy
school in New York office
of the president in Ukraine complaining
that they promised
not to attack Russian territory.
And that was a year ago.
And at that time,
Ukrainian officials
even turned to me and was asking
whether it was indeed
the Russian partizans or not.
And they was giving them
information about about this.
But this time it's
it's about the occurrence
of what
what's happening in Moscow, for sure.
It's not Ukrainians
and it's out of French.
The reason why
anti-missile defense of Russia did not
intercept those drones were
because those drones were launched
right next to Moscow.
Hmm.
What do you think
the real impact of this attack
on Putin was,
if it is, in fact,
these Russian partizans, as you say,
do you think their objective
was achieved here?
Oh, we will see.
On the ninth, Wolf.
We obviously
the security measures in Moscow would be
tightened and I hope that
the Russian authorities
would make the right decision
to downsize the military parade,
that the objective
was to demonstrate Russians
that the war, indeed,
as you correctly said, is at home.
And that's no longer some work there.
Everybody has to be a site
to make this decision
that cannot just sit on the couch
and watch the TV or looking at
whether ours are winning
or somebody else's are winning.
That's that's the real war.
You know,
Russia touts its
security often
and its ability to protect Putin.
Do you think that this is embarrassing
to Putin?
Well,
I don't think there was
any immediate threat to Vladimir,
which because it was indeed
the was a video late
we saw back on the dawn of
one of Kremlin's buildings.
That can not affect
what you gentlemen theoretically,
even if you were in
in that particular building,
you would not be a
you would not be affected.
It's raised by his propaganda statements
that it was an assassination attempt.
Obviously, it was just as a symbolic act
that was done to get that,
to show that the parade
would be affected.
And that would be even
bigger embarrassment
if some drones would land
that the red square
on the very ninth of me
when all this
military equipment,
glorious military equipment.
Russia would be demonstrated that there.
All right, Ilya Ponomarev, thank you.
Interesting to hear your perspective
on this. Appreciate it.
Thank you.